with over 300 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable you couldn't get to them
all so if you didn't see machine
learning made easy with the cube flow
and a last file then stay tuned because
here's the rewind machine learning is an
incredibly useful approach to automating
tasks with data but how do you bring it
to multi cloud hybrid environments as an
entire stack applying it is about more
than just the algorithms it's also about
the infrastructure the data and all the
other components you want your machine
learning to be composable so it
accommodates all the data science tools
out there you want portability so it's
easy to go from prototyping models on
your laptop to running them unchanged in
production you want it to scale
effortlessly from you a small data
prototype to your huge data pipelines
you know what's really good
composability portability and
scalability containers and kubernetes
except if a data scientist wants to use
machine learning on kubernetes there are
so many things that have to be an expert
in first they need a second black belt
in addition to their machine learning
one enter cube flow the cloud native
machine learning platform built on
kubernetes to take care of the entire
stack queue please mission is to make it
easy for everyone to develop deploy and
manage portable distributed machine
learning on kubernetes and that means
everyone no extra black belts needed
cube so it gives you the components you
need for machine learning right out of
the box jupiter notebooks distributed
training model serving examples plus
customizable case net packaging that
lets you add your own ok but what about
the data app portability needs data
portability well that's what elastic
files for it gives you one click setup
and straightforward sync strategies all
without having to rewrite your
applications if your app can use POSIX
and FS a standard block object store you
can use the last a file so alas develop
this Kuebler means you have everything
you need for truly portable machine
learning there's a mountain of things to
take care of if you do it on your own
why not take the ski lift instead in the
full talk you'll see demos of cubes ax
and elastin file in action and what's
that I'm seeing here you can deploy cube
flow with a one step script
included in the download and that's
thanks to cube flow 0.2 which we've just
announced the latest version gives the
added bonuses like advanced tooling
including h2 as a platform and really
powerful hyper parameter tuning with k
tip we also have platform integrations
including auto scaling based on job
submission cloud specific accelerators
and VMs and data exfiltration prevention
data science is poised to revolutionize
every industry and cube flow is helping
by giving everyone a single environment
to do reproducible production rating
machine learning without having to know
all the gory behind-the-scenes details
and the momentum is incredible if you'd
like to see the full talk check out the
link in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
you
[Music]